[Music]
hello you just love us and my friends
this is guns in here welcome to the
thirty seventh episode of dirty chest
tricks in this episode I'm going to show
you a wonderful tricky line against
various Benoni setup from the white
perspective now the opening water can be
occur with a different sequence but they
all leads to the same so for example
here let's say white start with the
Moody fall and after the Moon Knight to
f6
white continue with Knight to c3 and
after the typical banana move CFI white
grab the space on the Queen side with
defy and when black challenges with a
six white can support it with E for the
second route to the same position can be
reached via this model that is d4 C Phi
D Phi Knight to f6 Knight to c3 e six
and the movie form when I check this
position in latest database I found out
that there are more than 150 games
played including some master games and
the more surprising thing is here the
most popular choice by black is he
captures d5 which in fact I am going to
prove in this video is a big time
mistake from the black perspective the
correct continuation here for the black
is to play d6 however at the end of this
video I'm going to show you a tricky
line where you can trap some of your
opponents but first thing first I need
to concentrate what is wrong with he
captures d5 which looks very natural
destroying the white center
and get typical benoni advantage well
that's not right in this position
because of the white lethal reply ePHI
and after this move no matter however
black plays he get completely lost
position in just five move of the game
isn't that sound wonderful so let's see
how we can achieve this well as I have
highlighted over here black has few
choices but none of them turns out very
well the first move I want to consider
is d4 which is already a mistake by
black and the simplest repetition is you
can take this knight on f6 and after
black recapture overnight you can see
that juicy hold on e7 and after the move
Queen Jack Black is by force losing a
piece so that is straight out of the
equation what happens if he continued
with Queenie seven well nothing special
we can obviously continue here with
Queen to e2 renewing the threat of
capturing the night and Knight has the
only move left Knight to g8 which at
least save a piece but after Knight
captures defy attacking the Queen as
well as looking at c7 so black responds
his force black has to play Queen to d8
and then comes Bishop to f4 and I think
after this move White has put his
winning stamp within the eight moves of
the game there's a one master game
continue from here Knight to e7 which
looks very natural trying to get rid of
the attacker but then white give him
this ultimate shock BAM hahaha
so not only threatening the c7 but there
is also he captures f7 in their black
response is almost forced he captured
this Knight but there comes he captures
f7 check a double check so
has to capture the spawn and the
sequence afterwards happen which is even
a beginner can find out it's very easy
yup you start with the McQueen Czech
attacking to piece and if black continue
to save his piece with King to e6
then comes Quinn - if I came to f7 Quinn
captures DF I came to e8 and castle on
the Queen side
ahaha and I can't stop laughing
looking at this position where black
hasn't developed a single piece and on
top of everything his King cannot castle
and remain in the center to give white
all the fun he wants
fortunately I also reached this position
in one of my blitz game where my 2188
opponent continued with the move Knight
to a6 his idea is very obvious he want
to control the c7 square but what he
missed is White's ultimate reply boom
ahaha
typical sacrifice occurs in such a
positions where black king is stuck in
the center high-end try well black
doesn't have a choice he has to capture
this night and after pawn takes not only
white he's going to regain his piece but
after the move Castle you wonder the
faith of that black King which is never
going to be safe on either side the
third option you black and try over here
is Knight to e4 but this is hardly a
good option because after the move
Knight captures defy if black is not
careful enough then he's going to lose a
piece for example let's say a routine
move by black such as Knight to c6 is
not good at all the simple reason is
after the move Queen to e2 Knight to g5
and now Bishop captures g5 and black
emerge with a piece advantage as Queen
cannot capture this bishop due to this
wonderful for coup so it is very obvious
here that black has to do something to
evacuate his knight as quickly as
possible
so one idea is to play a seafood
immediately but then after white will
continue with Bishop capture c4 and a
simple line can run like this night to
see Phi Queen to h5 so there's a threat
of Knight to f6 which black has to deal
with Knight 26 and after the Moon Knight
to f3 with the naked eye you can see
that white has a superior pistol of man
and on top of it
he's a clear pawn of them so even though
black has managed to survive his Knight
his position is hardly playable in the
database 1 game continue from here at 6
so black is trying to rescue his Knight
with Knight to g5 but I think white is
point very accurately with Queen to h5
stopping Knight to g5 ok black continue
with the move Bishop to e7 before we
look at Bishop to e7 I like to quickly
point out that c4 now is nearly
impossible the simple reason is after
Bishop captures c4 Knight to c5 White
has this little blue knight to f6 and
King cannot go to the e7 due to the
Queen f7 mage so that means by force
black has to give up the Queen and who
will not enjoy Quin prick fast oddly in
the opening so probably that's the
reason why black here continue with the
moon Bishop to e7 thinking that he can
easily save his piece but after the
following move by white h4 that night is
completely a goner
he played d6 but after Bishop to d3
Black has suffered for the rest of the
game with a piece down and in fact did
lose the game last but not least the
most critical response here by black is
to play Knight to g8 accepting that he
has a worse position but still managed
to hold on into the middle game okay
white will continue with Queen captures
defy and now two major replies has been
tried in this position and none of them
walking very good the first move I want
to consider is a knight to e7 which on
the surface looks good because it's
attacking the Queen and develop a piece
but after the move Queen to e4 White has
a simple threat of Knight to be fire and
Knight to d6 which black prevents
immediately with a six but there comes
Bishop to e3 attacking the c5 pawn and
black needs to play d5 where resulting
position is quite good for the white I
have attached this line in the PGN but
let's see what happens we're a 2,300
phase this line and continue with Knight
to g6 which is very obvious defending
the c5 on the funny part I found about
this game is black has takes so many
moves for this night for example this
Knight goes from here back to g8 then
coming to he 7 and then going to g6 and
for tempo with one move not a good sign
so what can easily exploit this with a
four trying to get a fire in and create
some big problems in the black camp
black continued with Bishop to e7 so
probably I think his idea is to play
Knight to f8 after the mu F I and in
fact fi happens in the game night to a
fate indeed played so so far it looks
like black is holding on but afterwards
next reply black immediately resign and
I think you can spot this it's very easy
Epic's and the black tower is stuck in
the center of the ball
in the second game black continued with
Knight to c6 which looks more logical
but still after Bishop to c4 I think
black is not out of the wool as white
attack will continue on a smooth track
ok black has to defend f7 so he played
Queen to e7
now comes Knight and G to E - so already
white in terms of peace development
quite ahead in the game and there's
always problem when you play moves such
as Queen to e7 as your king side piece
development will be hindered for a long
time in the game black find nothing
better to capture on ePHI and white put
the 5th gear in terms of peace
development with Bishop to f4 black took
light square bishop white recapture and
now you see the drawback of Queen to e7
as White has these deadly threats of
Knight to defy a night to be file and I
don't think so black and parry both of
them in the game black continue with the
move d6 so at least he's trying to get a
counter attack on the White Queen
but after castle on the Queen side
brush up to e6 Queen to e4 check Queen
to d7 black is desperate to exchange the
Queen but of course white is not a mad
person he continued with Knight to be
Phi and seriously this is just too much
for the black one who has been played
rook to see a but after Bishop captures
d6 it's time to pack in
before I finished this video I like to
show you a tricky line when the opponent
plays the accurate response such as d6
in this position and after the move
Knight to f3 now black can definitely
capture this pawn he captures defy is a
normal response but I like to point out
here the interesting trap Uihlein Knight
captures defy which again
gambit a whole efore pawn and if you
open and take this pawn then he is
seriously asking for the trouble of
course we need to see what happens if
Knight captures efore after all black
wins upon white will continue with Queen
to e2 attacking the knight and black has
the only saving resource f5 which
actually looks efficient and first time
when I see this position I thought hang
on what is white going to do now well
here is the answer
what has this little move Bishop to g5
which turn out has a too strong for the
black Queen to F I check bishop to d2
and queen doesn't have any good square
except going back to DA so if you are
playing a higher seeded opponent you can
get a draw very easily but my
recommendation is you can continue with
the move Knight to g5 and create more
problems in the black camp okay by force
black is going to lose this Knight and
at the end it will be a check to the
black king
so most popular choice here is Bishop to
e7 blocking the e-file but now comes the
very simple move Knight captures a four
pawn captures a fool and Queen captures
a fool ok material is balanced but you
can easily see that for a long time
black is not going to castle on the
Kings side and that will give you all
the time in the world to build up a
strong attack
a sample game in a database goes as
follows black plays Knight to c6 white
plays Bishop to c4 black continued with
Knight to e5 trying to get that bishop
white plays castle on the Queen side and
after nightcap to c4 Queen kept a c4
still black and not Castle so he
continued with Bishop to e6 trying to
pin down that night white plays very
obvious move rook h2 even attacking the
bishop and maybe white thought well I
can exchange some pieces and then my
king will be very safe so he took on
this night but after Queen captures it
doesn't matter whatever black plays he
get a lost position for example in the
game he continued with Queen to d7
trying to defend b7 but what he all look
is White's major threat Bishop to g5 and
by force black is going to lose a piece
and in fact the game very very quickly
well I hope you enjoy and on this
wonderful tricky setup against various
Benoni opening and personally I found
out that many players are not aware of
this tricky line well thank you for
watching this video and good luck for
trying this line in your own game feel
free to write subscribe and comment on
this video and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care